I've never had any type of vegetarian
alternative to anything so I've never
had a veggie burger what is that I love
everything about like not just the sushi
I love ginger
I love wasabi yeah my sister gave me a
spoon of wasabi when I was a little kid
and I think I just became addicted I was
a vegetarian for four years and then I
had to make an exception for sushi so I
became pescetarian now since my
girlfriend is recently a vegetarian now
I've been looking all around the around
the city for vegetarian restaurants that
both me and her can get food at I've had
very sad vegetarian sushi which is why
it became pescetarian if it tasted just
like sushi I'd be happy with vegetarian
sushi maybe I can eat a little bit less
fish and be kinder to the earth
hey guys my name is guy I'm the chef and
owner of beyond sushi
I think of beyond sushi is something
that no one is doing out there its first
healthy and not just vegan because now
all vegan food is healthy necessarily we
don't fry anything and everything is
balanced and unique so you won't find
these combinations anywhere else for me
it's all about the package and the
balance between the flavors when you
when you eat and colors and textures and
everything that comes with it spicy man
has black rice English cucumber avocado
mango on the inside it's topped off with
semi pickled cabbage carrots and peppers
the spicy mango is one of my favorite
flavors so I'm excited about this one
it looks very fancy I love little
dollops of sauce I thought that's so
cute the plating is beautiful let's get
that right so already we're beyond sushi
in one sense of the word
[Music]
I think it's delicious I don't know if I
would feel like I was eating sushi I
feel like I'm in my own kind of like
food no although I guess like the
experience we're having the way we just
ate it makes it really sushi like I love
the spice of it it has a really nice
kick to it also tastes really healthy
vegetarianism aside the la fiesta has
sliced Ryota pickled jalapenos avocado
and it's topped off with a black bean
puree tomato guajillo sauce and a kaffir
like a fairly Clym chips UT man beauty
Gary and ceramic ball yeah it has like
the same consistency as if it had fish
in it
I could literally go knocked out there
yeah I can't tell that it doesn't have
fish all no because it has like some
kind of fish seasoning I also feel like
this could be like a good breakfast
dinner like Eddie's everything that even
like midnight snack when you don't wanna
have like that guilty conscience and
you're like I want to get up right now
grab something like having two of these
at like 3 o'clock in the morning I feel
like you'll be okay I don't really do
that much from vegetables so the fact
that I'm just eating rolled up
vegetables
it's like surprisingly so amazing
pickle me has six grain rice on the
outside marinated carrots pickled a yama
go bow which is a board accrued a
pickled daikon and it's topped off with
an avocado layer and a carrot ginger
sauce do you say boat a crew boat ack
yellow I don't know what this stuff is
I've never even heard of these
vegetables but I think that's the cool
thing about vegetarian options is
because once you start to explore them
you start to explore all these different
types of vegetables that you never knew
existed and so many different flavors it
actually looks like there's raw fish in
there do you see that I'm excited smells
like seafood though like no way don't
yeah yeah yeah I smell the sea bream
that's what it is
that [ __ ] is bombed it's like still
coming in like flavors are still coming
and the texture kind of reminds me of
like yellowtail so that's cool they're
sweet
so ginger carrot hmm
this is the DN Erica proved I don't know
any vegetarians unfortunately but I
think anybody would love this place my
favorite part of sushi is always like
the mango on top right yeah they're like
different like flavors that they add to
the actual sushi and this is just like a
combination of all the good toppings
meeting is a not vegetarian I think this
would be such a great place to get
dinner with a vegan or vegetarian friend
so it kind of reminds you that there's a
lot about sushi that's not in the sushi
and the fish itself ironically I really
enjoyed this experience as someone who
is mostly vegetarian someone who usually
eats plant-based things I love all the
flavors I love how beautiful the rules
look they are much better than a sad
cucumber roll and I would come back
nothing come back it's awesome you have
healthier sushi in healthier pockets who
wouldn't want that
[Music]